but if you start going out with single
friends or potentially going to places
where you know maybe the vibe isn't
right or they've heard they claiming
drama or things have happened in the
past that's when we get worried you know
I'm trying to say to you but we're not
trying to stop a woman from ever going
out but we'll get concerned when you
start going out too much and you put
yourself in situations where magnets
start hitting up to you and then there's
alcohol flowing and and you know
whenever people say I made a mistake or
I was drunk that's never happened when
someone wasn't drunk and they didn't
make a mistake so you have to take a lot
of these scenarios out and we know women
cheat as much as men do so there has to
be someone doing the cheating and if we
talk about women having women are the
ones with the gateway gateway sorry The
Gatekeepers the sex then once you add in
nightclub what you're adding out with a
single whole friends watch out what
you're adding alcohol once you add in
all of these other factors and the fact
that you can make a mistake well human
how about we just try to just take away
some of these factors that's all I'm
saying